il travaillait fort un gros trois mois
intenses
christine girard n'en revient toujours
pas du cadeau qu'on lui a fait la
famille de l'artiste peintre johanne
corno lui à l'idée plusieurs canevas
pots de peinture et outils de travail
qui ont appartenu à l'artiste qui est
décédé d'un cancer de la gorge en 2016
elle en a fait une collection son
honneur quand ça c'est fait j'ai vécu un
moment
touchant mais très agréable aussi on à
l'artiste christine girard travailler
dans un contexte différent
avec une histoire d'amour avec le
matériel de l'artiste johanne fait que
c'est une rareté
c'est une exclusivité pour moi c'est un
bon moment cette toile c'est l'hommage
accord nous c'est le magnolia
pour moi c'est un défi c'est de la
douceur de la barre je trouve vraiment
qu'elle repose en on est dans l'esprit
aussi de quelqu'un qui m'a accompagné
tout pendant tout le long
j'ai terminé j'ai terminé ma production
seul avec le tableau donc seul avec
johann puis j'ai un
j'ai signé le tableau avec la spatule de
johann hay avant sa mort corneau qui
entre autres exposés à new york voulait
laisser davantage de place à la relève
cette exposition est donc une fierté
pour sa famille tiens ma galerie est je
voudrais qu on pas sa place comme deux
fois par année à des des plusieurs
artistes et gens qui ont peu de
malchance puis sa réponse que johan
recherchait aussi parce qu'aussi tranche
que ça puisse paraître
joan dans le fond me disais dans la
dernière année de sa vie qu'à voyait ses
tableaux ses futurs tableau joint à mes
rêves j'ai tout le temps de ce samedi
or des fleurs dans mes tableaux il va
avoir encore avec cette exposition qui
rend hommage à la vie christine girard
espère qu on se souviendra que corneau
n'avait pas de limites à ses rêves un
peu comme elle qui expose enfin dans la
galerie de son idole ici à landry d'un
orage au canada montréal